las palabras de biden ya anticipaban una
nueva escalada de tensión entre ambos
países el kremlin considera a los
estadounidenses impredecibles y avisa de
que por eso tiene en cuenta todos los
posibles escenarios en los que se pueda
colocar su principal rival geopolítico
como primer gesto de protesta por las
palabras de byd en el ministerio de
exteriores de rusia ha llamado a
consultas a moscú al embajador ruso en
eeuu anatoli antónov la razón para este
movimiento fue examinar el futuro de las
relaciones entre ambos países así lo
anunció la portavoz de la cancillería
rusa maria sharapova que aseguró que aún
así
moscú está interesado en impedir un
deterioro irreversible de las relaciones
siempre y cuando eeuu se dé cuenta de
los riesgos que está asumiendo por su
parte el presidente de la duma estatal
la cámara baja del parlamento ruso
viácheslav volodin ha calificado a las
palabras del líder estadounidense sobre
putin como un insulto a los rusos y una
histeria fruto de la impotencia que
siente eeuu ante el poder de rusia